[Music]
welcome to the data science hangout i'm
rachel be your host
if you're joining for the first time
thank you for joining us um
special welcome to those who have been
joining us week after week it's great to
have you here
if this is your first data science
hangout this is an open space for the
whole data science community
to connect and chat about data science
leadership questions you're facing
what's going on in the world of data
science
i'll just add this too if i transport
into the future and you're watching this
on link on youtube for the first time
you can also join us live and we would
love to have you here so there should be
a link that i'll make sure we'll put in
the youtube descriptions too
just like to reiterate we love to hear
from everyone no matter your level of
experience or area of work as well
but with all that i'm so happy to be
joined by my co-host for today
mike smith
mike is a senior director of statistics
at pfizer
mike i'd love to have you introduce
yourself and maybe share a bit about
your work
sure um so
i've worked at pfizer for 29 years this
year
um i have
started in statistics group
i
then went to the modeling and simulation
group in clinical pharmacology
uh where i was essentially
leading the or or kind of helping mostly
with the simulation side of things
so taking models that other colleagues
have built and then doing predictions or
simulations for clinical trial design
to try and assess operating
characteristics and you know come up
with the most efficient design possible
so
i've then moved back to statistics now
um
where i am i call myself a professional
geek
okay so
i have looked after our our installation
our package sets
getting that into the hands of my
colleagues
kind of looking at what's coming out in
the ru ecosystem finding out what uh
packages you know essentially being at
the bleeding edge of what's coming to to
help train them but also
you know it prevent that wheel spin
where instead of every colleague having
to do
um you know look at different tables
packages and going oh what's the pros
and cons of all these different tables
package if i do that then i can provide
a kind of
best guess for them um
to to come
come up with that
uh
last year before arn pharma i did a
little
poll and i found out that over 1500
colleagues had downloaded r
um so if you can imagine i'm an our
subject matter expert for
somewhere in the region of you know
between 600 people who are on my ms
teams channel
and you know the 1500 who have
downloaded it
so i i'm trying to
you know service that community build a
community find out what other people are
doing and share that
um
lastly uh
i i should say that
we're a very decentralized model
within pfizer where for data science and
using r there are pockets of people and
throughout all of pfizer who do some
really awesome stuff with r
um and you know so
i'm in this new center of excellence
team that we're just setting up i'm
trying to kind of
build connections between all of those
smes and also help the teams where there
isn't an sme available
so
uh cat herding is definitely on my job
description professional geek in fact we
talked about it at uh last week's
meeting
which is about being that translator
role
between the the users the business
people who are out there doing stuff and
need solutions with our and the
technical side of folks who are building
things
i definitely sit in that space
so i you know
i'm here at data science
hangout but i've never fitted a machine
learning model in my life
so
if you've got questions about that
you'll need to turn to one of my
esteemed colleagues but um for from the
translation bit and the general kind of
cat herding that's why i'm here
love it mike
that's so impressive that survey had
that many respondents too i'm curious
how you even
launched that out to everybody
um i didn't i
i have the i have a
a means of querying the microsoft
database that sits behind the process
that
people grab are
and so by querying that directly i can
pull out how many people have got
our see that's awesome
steph i see you had to ask the question
in the chat if you want to jump in
yeah sure nice to meet you mike um
that's awesome to hear congrats on 29
years that's that's very impressive
and inspiring um
so
i guess the question would be that's a
lot of our users and is there some
central infrastructure that you guys
leverage to
make sure that your environments are
kind of consistent between all users or
kind of all the teams kind of have their
own little
infrastructure
we are
we've had
our installed on our high performance
compute grid now for many many years so
like 15 years or so
so for production use that's where
colleagues should be running things
and
within the last
three years really we've got our studio
products so we have our studio server
pro
and in the last two years we've got
docker containers
um this brings up
a whole kind of worms set because
and i should say that desktop now i'm
kind of saying to colleagues look if you
load up on your desktop and you download
packages from wherever and i don't know
what you've got and i don't know what
versions you've got
that's effectively your sandbox
you know don't
so that
the the other bit that goes with this is
that anything that we submit to
regulatory agencies
we need to know
what version you ran what packages you
used
and it needs to be reproducible in the
long term
so the regulators can and sometimes do
come back to us 10 years later and say
can you rerun that analysis but look at
this subset or add in this data or you
know questions like that so we need to
be able to run stuff from 10 15 years
ago
so that's why i'm kind of saying to them
look you know leave your desktop
for
playing because when you go to a
conference tomorrow and you have to load
up a set of packages for this workshop
you're on you'll forget to swap back to
the standard set
right
wow 10 years
a long time
i see yeah i mean the other the other
funny side of that is that on the hpc
grid we have version r191
right but i don't know how to program it
anymore
i'm so used to tiny verse and new ways
of doing things that i'm gonna like ah
it's gonna be a problem
thanks mike i see there's a few
anonymous questions coming in right now
as well and
one is what are the differences between
being a director of statistics versus
let's say a director of data science
i'm a senior director within the
statistics department so um
if you're a senior director within a
data science group
you might be doing
as i said the
data science is used broadly in many
many different places at pfizer
um for all kinds of different um
needs
you know like in drug development
uh terms they're building machine
learning models to
to look at the
the aspects of like when you take when
you actually compress a tablet
you know does that hold together
machine learning is used there machine
learning is used in real world data so
outside of the clinical trial process
so really the the kind of distinction
between
you know me sitting here doing my stuff
being a professional geek in stats
versus being sitting anywhere else
within pfizer doing data science
um you know it's we all kind of
do the things that we need to do
um
but the
there isn't
there are many
people
whose role will be called data scientist
but we don't necessarily have a data
science department
if that helps answer that question
yeah and i i think that kind of touches
on your question in the chat as well
frank if you want to jump in
so for sure it it touches on it um
a slightly different way to think about
it but i don't think there's going to be
a really concrete answer here um the
difference between data analytics and
data science or like what's called
statistics and data science
uh
people have said to me like who cares
right like they're both they're using
these tools and these methodologies and
we're all solving problems making
decisions using data
it matters though right like especially
at large corporations like pfizer or
like target
you use these terms and people
automatically right especially non-dated
people like have these automatic
perceptions of what they are and they're
like okay this many dollars over here
this million dollars over here like more
head count for you less for you
so right and like the problem is though
everyone had
we all know like everyone on this call i
think knows
it's so
messy right like the delineation is so
messy and i was just curious i don't
know if you have perspective on that
cool if not i understand that too
yeah i i mean
the the place it seems to matter frank
is in job descriptions when you're
posting
for new positions
um
i think
kind of my experience is that
there are
people throughout the organization
who are
making decisions with data
or helping others make decisions with
data
um
but you know those could be called
statisticians those could be called data
scientists you know clinical
pharmacologists and pharmaceuticals that
i talked about previously
are building models right it's not
necessarily you know deep learning or
[Music]
xg boosts but it's non-linear mixed
effects modeling
um and and doing that kind of stuff so
it
i think once you're through the door
that distinction really melts away
um
it right as you said said that i thought
is it
worth thinking about it right if i'm if
i'm interviewing for a data x role is it
worth asking how closely do i work with
the users the operators the decision mak
whatever like call whatever you will the
decision makers
and maybe that gives the the person
interviewing better context for maybe
maybe like realistically what they'll be
doing right the data scientist that
never gets to work on ml
is going to be confused right yeah
yeah
no that's right so
i guess i'm just conscious of the fact
that if you go and type in data
scientists into the pfizer careers
website
you're going to get a a whole heap of
jobs
but you're also going to
look at some of them and go but that's
not data scientist as i understand it
right yeah
and
you know it you're right when when
you're doing your job you don't want to
get into a job and realize that no one
has ever used it machine learning never
used machine learning models in this
space at all before
and that's you know well why was i hired
here but at the same time
you know people are in many pockets
using data to make decisions
and i think you know that's a that's a
common skill set
regardless of whether you've ever fitted
a machine learning model
absolutely
okay
i appreciate it
that's great
there are a lot of great questions
coming in and i'm not going to try and
group them together on topic because
it's too hard at the same time but i see
ethan you asked a great question around
hiring if you want to jump in and ask
that
yeah i just want to um hello mike
nice to meet you
um i just want to ask the questions
around
hiring advisors because i remember
one of your posts about
hiring practice and then you've recently
implemented some new hiring factors at
pfizer mainly around like problem
solving so just wondering what sort of
skill set
expertise
matter more
advisor do you look for
med students who has a bit of our
knowledge and you train them up in r or
do you look for people who are
proficient in on with a bit of interest
in
clinicals and medicines and
you can build that expertise at all
that that's
that's a really good question
i think it depends on the role
right
so
um
as i mentioned the clinical pharmacology
pharmacometrics and stats groups
um
they're likely to come in with either
clinical pharmacology or pharmacy
degrees
and learn r as they're doing it
um
same with statisticians
but right at the minute i'm looking for
technical r
specialists
right who know how to turn an expression
of a problem into an r
thing whether it's a function or a
package or shiny app or markdown report
so it really is context specific um
we're such a massive organization that
it's
you know i
if you come in with a physics degree but
you have a long history of developing
really cool art packages on github
you know that's that i want to talk to
you
um
but first
for for stats roles and and typically
within the stats department within the
clinton farm department they're looking
for people with that specific uh
background or degree
and then
they'll learn r and various other things
thank you
i think seeing that our center of
excellence in the
job positions
helps a bit too for
getting the word out there
i see there was anonymous question too
that was what are the standard gaps in
background knowledge in a new data
science hire
yikes um
i mean obviously we're all looking for
the unicorns right who who have all of
the skill set um
and
it is a
it is a tricky problem when you're
hiring and you're trying to weigh up the
strengths and weaknesses of each of the
candidates or trying to rank them
um
with the roles i have in mind
for the our center of excellence
um
obviously strong r skills are are
prerequisite for that
um
but then after that you you get into
these things of well
has this person got experience building
a community because obviously that's
another big feature of this role
um
have they got experience at problem
solving so the the kind of
translator role if you will that we
talked about before of
when you hear a problem
you know your mind's thinking over
how do i
solve that problem using things i know
about
packages
or apps or functions
um
and so if the person's really strong on
one or more of those things then you can
often fill in the blanks
um
and
again i'm sorry but it's largely role
dependent
um
there are very few people that arrive
fully formed and that you can just go
yeah you work
um get to work
and
i would just say that i i think that the
people that we bring in
um
you know you would try and help them
plug the gaps that they have
um
but i think it's it's hard if someone's
completely missing something
if they have some experience but you
know it it could be
increased or
or
better then you can work on that and you
know as long as the kind of core things
you're looking for are there
um
[Music]
i mean i'm
delighted to hear other how other people
who are hiring
try and make that call
because it seems to me it's very hard
yeah feel free to jump in everyone
give people a few more seconds i see
steven you just unmuted if you want to
jump in yeah just just just just to add
this in in in my experience the big
issue is finding people who can wrangle
data rather than do machine learning
everybody wants to do machine learning
you have to understand the data before
you can
learn from it
yeah
yeah that's that's certainly true
great point
i know it's been a while since we also
did introductions too so feel free to
introduce yourself when you ask the
question as well
but jordan i see you asked a great
question earlier in the chat too if you
want to jump in
um
yeah so if i remember correctly my
question was about um any pushback that
you've had with um
sort of introducing r into uh the
workspace as opposed to
the
sort of um
assumed giant within pharma sas um
assuming that there's many people in
there that are very amazing sas
programmers who still blow my mind today
but have you had any
have you had to work with that sort of
well we already have sas and sas
programmers yr
yeah
that's
certainly true um
i mean it's
it's fortunately that decision
kind of has to come from the managerial
level
so the kind of top level within the
programming organization
has uh
you know it if they make that call that
we are going to transition from sas to
our
you know it
i can't push from the bottom up because
it's just the number of people's too big
um but if that person decides and and it
comes down from from that level
then you've still got a battle because
there are some people who
you know feel well
i'm a competent sas programmer i know
nothing about our
how the heck do i make a switch
and that's where you know you need to
train and keep training
um and you know
try and help those people
make the switch
there are many good kind of sas to our
training courses um available now
and you know that there are many are
training courses which are really
excellent
one of the places that i find
you can do a really
quick win
is if the sas programmer knows a proc
sql
then if you show them d plier it's kind
of like well okay those two things look
broadly similar so you just swap those
in and you're off and the other place of
course is in the the back end of stuff
of visualizations and markdown and you
know things like that that
you know sas program that's those are
things that sas don't doesn't do quite
so well and so you can win hearts and
minds in that sense and then you're kind
of gradually migrating towards it
following up on that too there was an
anonymous question that was what's the
proportion of sas versus spss vsar and
versus python at your organization
well within the stats organization it's
about 5050 sas and r
um
for i would being a statistician of
course i'd like a breakdown of
years of experience because it seems to
me that people who are coming in now
to the organization are much more likely
to have seen our college
and and you know done stuff
uh at college with r compared to sas
because it seems to me that you know in
the way that we used to work we would
bring people in and then train them in
sas
because the cost of entry there is
fairly high
i can't speak about the rest of the
organization um
but yeah it's
that's what i've seen just within the
stats group
thank you
another question that was asked a bit
earlier was what is the trend of data
science job in big pharma like pfizer
will adopting r and big pharma
then sas increase the data science jobs
um
i
i don't know that it's related to
the software
you know the thing that's indisputable
is that the amount of data we're getting
is just getting more and more and more
and more and more groups within
the organization
are turning to people who can wrangle
that data
and make decisions and and you know
present back evidence for making a
decision
using tools whatever those tools are
um and you know back to the original
point that frank made is that person a
data scientist
you know that that's that's for someone
writing the job role to decide um
but
it's it we're getting much more data
much more is being asked of us with that
data
um
and you know being a regulatory
regulated industry we need to be able to
present that data back to
regulators and you know to underwrite
our claims and
uh provide evidence for them to make a
decision
i'm sorry if that's horribly big
whoever asked the question if you demand
more information from mike
into the chat
but sam i see you asked uh about shiny
do you want to jump in and and ask that
question
and i can
of course read the question if you want
to jump in and add more context please
feel free
but sam asks how do you see shinee being
used at pfizer in the next few years
um
it's
it's increasing a lot within over the
last five years certainly
uh five years is that fair has it been
around for more than five years
certainly let's say two years
um
i'm seeing
many
groups
who feel that everything needs a shiny
app
you know everything every solution is
shiny shaped
um
because the instant that people want to
do something interactive that's where
they turn
what i'm trying to do is
but with shiny comes an overhead right
because you've got to host it somewhere
you've got to maintain it and then
you've got to
think about how to
not just maintain that code base but
then improve on it and make sure that it
works with the next generation of
whatever
so i'm trying to kind of
be a
a counter balance to that to say
is the interactivity you're looking for
served via like plotly or via
parameterized or markdown report or
something like that
um
so
yeah
the the interactivity that people have
with shiny means that you can set
something up
and provide guardrails
for whoever is consuming that that app
to look at their data more slice it dice
it look at subsets and just understand
what's going on in the data much better
so
yeah i can see the appeal but i'm also
trying to say well you know is that
really the right
tool for this
this situation
yeah that's a great point
do you i mean mike do you also
have tableau or some other kind of
visualization platform like
so there's a balance there right because
you don't want to start replicating
stuff in shiny that
can clearly be done in another platform
that you're
honestly already paying for
yeah absolutely
jesus i i see you have your hand raised
if you want to jump in
yeah i just had a question so um
you were seeing this push to relabel
some data scientists as research
research software engineers
and so that's what i would describe
myself so i'm at a national us national
lab now and we have people that come to
us that have data science problems
and so we help you know code that
product or that problem in r and maybe
deploy until we have an r studio connect
server um would you feel that's kind of
the best way to describe what data
scientists some data scientists are
becoming
or do you think you know adding this
term
research software engineer into the word
cloud is just going to be you know more
noise
oh
um
and of course there's also ml ops so
which kind of
kind of describes it too
yeah
i
i i know what you're talking about and i
think that
you know you could also describe large
parts of what i see some colleagues
doing as
a research
software engineer
that that would describe quite well what
some people are doing
um
but again it's back to terminology and
it's you know
if if you describe your role as a
research software engineer
then will anyone outside of that group
really know what you're doing
um
it may also
to be honest it may depend on what part
of the organization you're sitting in
right so if you're more aligned to an
i.t department
you know people might be like yeah i i
totally understand where you're coming
from and what you're doing
if you if you were
within statistics and you describe
yourself as a re research software
engineer people might say well what are
you doing sitting in statistics
um
you know and it it's just
i guess with a company the size of
pfizer
you know and and with this even the size
of the statistics group which is 200
people
you know
it's then you have to try and
you know tell the people within the
organization what it is you do
yeah
well you know i i know in
pharmaceuticals and a lot of my um
classmates went on to do this and they
became sas programmers right at
pharmaceuticals and you can consider
that a software recent engineer right
they really don't do any statistics
anymore they just help people write sas
code
or you know um if you had someone that
had some
are
some r code and they wanted to package
it and you know they don't know how to
make a package they don't know how to
deploy that package they don't know how
to um host this package that's where a
research software engineer would step in
yeah and and i'm sure there are people
within the organization who are
essentially doing that
in fact i one of my colleagues that i
work closely with is probably doing
something
very much like that job but i'm not sure
what their official job title
is i can imagine for people looking for
new jobs it's hard as well with so many
different titles right right what do you
search for
right
yeah
nessa i see you asked a great question
in the chat a bit earlier if you want to
jump in
yeah i can do um this is obviously me
asking a question from my own personal
benefit but yeah i was
let me scroll up to watch it i actually
said um yeah i was wondering if
you'd worked with any synthesis chemists
who had turned into data scientists
and
particularly asking in the sense of what
what they tend to lack from a data point
of view i mean from my point of view
you know my entire background is in
chemistry um i
i would like to stick with that but turn
it into more of a data perspective on
chemistry
[Music]
yeah
it's
we had a discussion internally with uh
some folks in the um
pharmaceutical r d group who are our
pharmaceutical sciences group or the
the colleagues who are designing the
you know turning the molecules into
tablets essentially
and you know the the skill set they were
looking for in people doing data science
there was a massive overlap with
the you know what the the statistics or
our part of the world were looking for
you know in terms of
managing code
writing the appropriate tools
maintaining them rolling them out um
as well as you know machine learning
bits
um i i think
i nessa it depends on whether you're
saying i want to become a data scientist
and then come and work over here within
a completely different realm you know do
data science but in finance or due to a
science and somewhere else
as we discussed last week i think where
we were talking about
um
is it easy to
you know come with or
the question that was asked earlier do
you if you come with a domain knowledge
you know we can teach you some bits over
here
but if you move to some other bits then
you rely on like the data science bit
being really super strong
and then learn the domain
um
now i
i
personally think that
um the domain knowledge i've picked up
allows me to more effectively solve
problems within my domain
yep right so
you know when scientist comes and and it
can't really
express what they want in terms of
you know
nuts and bolts so is it a shiny app is
it a markdown i that bit doesn't matter
to me it's like tell me what it is
you're going to do with this
you know your use case your user story
then i can think of you know how do i
solve that problem
that's good that's helpful thanks
thanks mike
and thanks nessa for the question too i
see sam you asked one in the chat and i
can read it for you
i actually wanted to ask mike the same
question
sam said it's really cool to see
pfizer's commitment to our programming
via our center of excellence
what led to the creation of this
initiative within pfizer
so
as i said previously we are
very kind of decentralized disparate
folks so there that are
are subject matter experts sitting
throughout the organization
and what we saw was that it's hard
sometimes to get
uh an effective strategy across people
you know because it's such a big company
if
six people within statistics that's like
six out of 200 are doing some cool stuff
in stats
then
is it easy for each other to know what
they're doing
and do we have six people who are all
trying to write the same function or the
right you know access the same data
um could we not
then say well let's solve this problem
once and then
make that into a package and serve that
out to everybody so that then that
streamlines their workflow for the
future
um
we also saw that there are places in the
organization and as we're kind of
discussing earlier that
lots of people want data science type
stuff for or research software engineer
type stuff of build build and stuff um
if they don't have
an our subject matter expert out there
we want to be able to help them
solve their problem
and kind of set them up with a proof of
concept or
build something quick pass it on to them
and say well here's here's a on our
markdown report if you need to change it
for a different endpoint or for a
different data set then change it here
but other than that you can then see
which bits to tweak
so we're because we're trying to serve
such a big organization
we're just seeing that having a
centralized place that can be strategic
it's on well
the other
let me put this positively um
there's
there's a benefit in being able to solve
problems strategically so we're not just
you know get the problem solve it get
out the door move on to the next but
we're trying to say
what pieces of lego can we manufacture
so that the next time we see a problem
like this we can lift that up and go
okay we're just cobbling together bits
here to solve problems quicker
or to break things down like you would
in building a package to say if we put
these fundamental functions into place
to access data or to render this as a
this thing
um
then
you know we can offer those to the
organization via a package or via
something that allows other people to
solve that problem for themselves
because if you don't have that
centralized place
then i fear that many people would just
go i just need to solve today's problem
i've you know this needs to be done by
tomorrow
i don't have a week to spend on this
but if we've spent a week earlier
then you could get it done much quicker
[Music]
i guess part of my question there too is
that
adding on to to what sam asks is
that i think a lot of big companies know
they need something like this
and like they see all these challenges
but
how do you actually go about
making it happen
and getting approvals to like make that
a real life thing
i was very lucky that
uh in september last year doug robinson
joined pfizer from novartis and doug had
set up exactly like this
uh rcoe in novartis
so when he walked through the door i i
pinned him against the wall and said we
need what you had
um
we then
went to
the head of stat programming
and said
we we can you know how about it
we'd like to do something like this
fortunately she said
110 behind you
so then she could then kind of be your
primary sponsor at the next layer up to
say
this is what we'd like to do
but it's still quite the thing when you
make the pitch to the head of the global
head of biometrics and data management
to say
we'd like to set up this group
and you know
have them endorse it and say yep
we need to do that
so you know it's it's it's a it's a
great thing
and and libby's having a having a
champion there is really what you need
because if you're fighting to do this
from the bottom
you're
going to have a long slog ahead
thanks mike
so one one more question about that then
so you said finding a champion but is
there another tip that you'd give
all of us listening in if we wanted to
do this
wait um
well i i was really lucky because i i
found someone who'd done it before
you know so
so doug had the expertise of
you know who do we need to tell what do
we need to tell them
you know what is our raison d'etre or
you know what's our purpose for being
you know and and he had all that kind of
ready to go
um
i suspect this is probably something
that we could add to your community's
website right
yes
i was thinking that would be helpful
yes you know who
what what's the rationale for it who do
you have to speak to who do you have to
convince and how do you convince them
right
definitely
i know there was a great question that
came in anonymously that i missed at the
very beginning but it was in those 29
years of being at pfizer what have been
the biggest changes you've seen in the
space at that time
um
that's a really
good question
i mean i've been here long enough that
uh when i started bayesian analysis was
just don't talk to me about that mike
you know nobody uses bayesian methods
around here
um and that's flipped now so that you
know
people are using design analysis i mean
the primary analysis of the vaccine
trial was a bayesian analysis
so that's that's great
um
and this is kind of related to something
that that libby brought up earlier which
is about decision making
um
we have moved
much much more to a situation where
decisions are being made off the back of
data
rather than
um
off the back of
project teams kind of saying well i saw
the last time we had a compound like
this or last time we were in this
situation this is what we did so that's
what we should do this time
um
i mean that it hasn't been like that for
a long time but still i think it's a big
deal
that the decision making is now much
more
you know show me a prediction show me a
simulation
you know
help me make this decision using data
that we've got
and off the back of a
model or a prediction or simulation
thank you
andy i i see you asked a question in the
chat that it looks like a lot of people
have been weighing in on as well if
you'd want to jump in and ask that live
hi sure thanks for taking the question
um
so any tips on how to
work with the it folks when we've got uh
folks in the team who are actively
opposed to the open source tools and i
i'll caveat on that i work in uh
government
so
folks in
public health are pretty protective of
what kinds of tools are installed in
even their cloud environments
and
so we're
um having to do a lot of
uh
uh
reinforming and unlearning because the r
that they think of when we talk about it
is probably circa
2007
r and um
you know um there's there's really quite
a silo between folks that are
um gearing themselves towards being data
engineers in i.t with it backgrounds
where they're basically
you know managing a data center and the
rest of us are just
using the tools they want to deploy
which has been fairly limited to the
microsoft suite um and you know well
while there's sort of a community
welling amongst the analysts
across various programs
um using our studio and
and wanting to use enterprise tools
enterprise level tools so that we can do
code sharing
um in a more
managed environment than the
um kind of wild west
working with right now
yeah so any tips on that and thanks for
the um i got the uh link to the
champions that's really helpful i'm
sending that link to several colleagues
right now okay
so
um
yeah i think
actively opposed is a hard one to fight
right because
you'll then find
um
people will sow fear uncertainty and
doubt
um
and that's hard to hard to battle
against in terms of
my work at pfizer um
for
almost for over 20 years now the fda has
said that they don't endorse any
specific tool for analysis
you know so there's a perception within
a company that oh if you're submitting
to the regulators to the fda it has to
be in sas
they make the request that the transfer
files that you pass to them of the data
are in sas format
but they've said for many many years
that
they don't care what software use and
they can't endorse any specific software
because they're a government agency and
you know they wouldn't stand behind
a particular company
and their software
so we've got that going for us
um
but the the other part of it that i
think is easier to manage is to take
away the the kind of wild west side of
things
so
when we deploy r at pfizer we talked
earlier about r and the high performance
compute grid
what we've got now is a process that
says we'll take a certain version of our
a certain set of packages and a certain
versions of those packages
we build it
we test it we document it and then it
goes under change control so that there
are no sudden changes to that instance
of r
and it's the same it's getting easier
now because we've got containers
for that so we we kind of test and
validate and qualify and document the
container and then deploy it in various
places
what that then means is that
as far as
you know no one can get in and install
packages
in that environment
unless it goes back through that whole
process
so that kind of then takes that wild
west away
in that framework
and
you know i'm i'm also militant about
telling my colleagues not to run
anything in production on their desktop
for the reasons that we discussed
earlier with it
you know i can't tell what they've got
and i can't tell what state it's in
so with those two messages i'm kind of
saying well look
anything that's on production needs to
come from here
you can do what you like on your desktop
but if you then try and run it over here
you know you can't come and tell me
oh i need to get this package in there
and i need it by tomorrow morning
because the answer is well it needs to
go through that whole cycle in order to
have the confidence that this snapshot
version here is still valid
um
if
my personal view is that if you lock
down something too much people will find
workarounds
so if they if you get told you cannot
use open source you must use
these this set of products
if that person wants to they'll find a
way to get around that and to sort it
out so if this way of doing things the
official way the good way of doing
things is easy
then you know
hopefully people will do that then this
this nasty work around over here
i like that make the good way of doing
things easy
ismail i see you added some um
a comment in the chat as well to answer
andy if you want to jump in
um yeah um so i kind of have a little
bit of experience with
uh trying to bring
leadership into a line to use like open
source tools especially from like a
financial institution that
uh sees everything as risk and actually
given examples like fi serve like
accenture like nasa that they use r and
r studio consistently
um
bring opens their mind to be like oh
maybe it's not so bad or for example at
the beginning uh we have to stay with
microsoft suite too
but like a 2017 version of visual studio
code has an r tools integration so until
you can prove your point of why it's a
good and how it's validated um i think
there's ways to do it around it
sometimes it just takes dedication and
finding the
the right combination i would say
thank you
i don't want to switch
gears to another topic if anybody else
wanted to to add anything
i too a quick comment this is santiago
and once on that on the subject of uh i
kind of get
folks to adopt to open source i once met
a small team at a bank
and they had this struggle to and they
worked with the regulators because what
they were working on was regulated they
used our open source libraries
and they worked with the regulators to
get everything audited approved it took
a little bit longer and it was a new
process
but by the end of it they had an open
source process that they adopted and
were able to replace their old
sas systems with
so it's doable awesome
yeah i hadn't heard of that before i
thought that was really interesting
thanks santiago
colin i i see you had asked a question
earlier i think in zoom chat around
reproducibility
do you want to ask that one live
oh i don't think we can hear you yet
unless it's on my end
i can start to
i can start to ask the question too um
but the question was how reproducible is
your analysis what's the probability of
running an analysis from one to five to
ten years ago and getting the same
answer
in terms of just the analysis
i would say that our probability is high
assuming that that analysis has been run
on our high performance compute grid as
a batch job right so if i
if i take a job that was run
you know a year ago and i re-run it on
the grid
then
you know because that tool is still
there i should be able to completely
reproduce that
as you go further back you know
10 years from now i'm hoping that we'll
still have 90
95 probability because you know we have
containers and things are locked down
the place where it gets
more challenging is from 10 years ago
from now
because
the high performance compute grid is a
shared resource across many many
different lines in pfizer
the
environment
that the tools are sitting on may have
changed slightly so you know compilers
may have changed slightly
things like that i would say that the
probability is still high
but it's maybe not as high as 10 years
from today
sorry we couldn't hear you colin
um stephen i see you had your hand
raised too if you want to jump in
yeah and i apologize in advance if i
derail the conversation totally
but i'm just curious as to whether
mike thinks that he that
his role as a either a data scientist or
a statistician has influenced his music
yes it does actually thanks for asking
that stephen i'll put the link to my
bandcamp later on so everyone can rush
out and buy it um
yes the
i incorporate random stuff
generative stuff into into my music so
yeah randomness and probability and all
of that features highly
thanks for the blog i'm camp frightening
you need to share this tomorrow
yes mike please share that in the chat
thanks stephen
i see ethan you had asked a question
earlier as well brown
um friction with introducing new tools
do you want to jump in
yeah so this is um
thank you rachel this is uh coming back
to the conversations around you know
building a centralized tool
for everyone to use did you have any
sort of friction trying to get people to
use it
because if people
have already built their own tool or
they're used to doing things their own
way
might be a bit difficult to convince
them to start using your tool
yeah so if this is the the kind of
central container of our and packages
i always have this friction where
someone will have developed something
with a package that isn't on my set
my set
um the official set
um and so they'll come and they'll say
hey i really need this
okay
if that happens
and
it's like a version of a package or a
package that
it makes sense that we should have
included this and we just somehow
managed to not include it
it's possible
to kind of layer in that package
we would need to look at the
dependencies of that package you know so
there's no point in layering in a new
package that you know breaks all the old
stuff because it needs a more up-to-date
deployer you know in that case i would
just say to them well
now is the time to go back to rn
do this and make it reproducible for you
in this project
as a special case
um
as i said the
layering in of new packages involves
re-testing re-qualifying re-documenting
signing off all of that kind of
process
so it's not trivial
and i tend to think that if we get to
that point where someone needs it for
tomorrow morning it's because they
weren't paying attention earlier
you know when i said you must use this
version over here to do a production run
um so it's possible it's
resource intensive and and expensive
um
but
now we can kind of at least say well
with rn create your own little project
get your own set of those packages you
need because then it's reproducible for
you
using our end
and and we'll deal with
making that um you know incorporating
that package into the next release
yeah because our rco made it so easy to
create projects and fun like control
everything
within it yes yeah
the thing that i sometimes find though
and this is why i try and get people off
their desktops
is when person x develops some code
passes it to person y and person y goes
oh it doesn't run mike can you help
you know even with our end it's a pain
to have to take all of that over to here
and reconstitute it constitute it and
re-run it and see what the problem is
i would much rather people kind of
work off this standard
because then i know if i use the docker
and you use the docker
we can share code we can share projects
so easily
you see like um moving towards our
studio cloud because that way everyone
is on the same versions okay well that's
that's kind of what we have with the stu
r studio server pro
so when you fire up our studio server
pro it will say what version
of r do you want to run and basically
that's saying pointing to the container
and saying use this container with this
r and these these packages
so that that's another option that we
have
today okay thank you
thanks season
um i know there's a few questions that
were asked earlier around this data
culture that you have at pfizer and
javier you had one earlier if you'd want
to ask that
hey thanks rachel
and uh mike this has been an awesome
talk i've loved hearing sort of your
experiences and what you're doing over
there pfizer
but you know one area where i have seen
a lot of
our programmers specifically i mean
that's
you know that's what i'm working in day
in day out so this might
expand to people programming in other
languages also but
i've noticed a really big problem where
at these larger corporations where you
have small armies of our programmers
um
there's not always a consistent
use of
syntax
or
framing of
the code or your apps or whatever it
might be
making it borderline impossible to
knowledge transfer or have someone come
in
and like
expect them to take over a complex app
build that was done
and so
i didn't know what might be the solution
to this like i hate telling people
we need to all code using let's say the
tidy verse style guide or whatever it
might be because i want i don't want to
know
like i don't want to be able to
differentiate between individuals when
i'm reviewing code
like my code should be indistinguishable
from your code
but
just in general what are your thoughts
on that
it
okay
it's you're right
the
heterogeneity between people
is massive
right and that's um
but that tends to be on
we have statisticians right who will
turn around and say i'm not a programmer
right and it's almost like you know so
so you don't need to beat me with a
stick about style guides because i'm not
a programmer
um
there are clinical pharmacologists and
pharmacometricians who will also tell me
i'm not a programmer and but they are
programming to get the work done for
today and get it out the door and answer
the problems and move forward
all i can do for them is to encourage
them
you know and say look if you use a style
guide then when this person comes to
review your code it'll be so much easier
for them to see what you're doing
you know and and again ed uh commenting
and all the rest of that
and in a sense that's
i encourage people to kind of use
markdown
for those statisticians and pharmacists
who are doing work because then you've
got
why am i doing this as well as the code
that says and here's how i'm doing it
when it comes to the programming
programming people so the statistical
programmers who are
coding up for for
regulating
building
visualizations and tables and reports
it matters more that those people follow
the style guide
i mean it's literally their job to
write code that is maintainable
and will last the distance and is easily
reviewed
so in that instance it's kind of well
those people ought to be following a
style guide
especially if that code is going to be
reused because then you know it needs to
be commented tested you know qualified
all the rest of it
um for everyone else
i can suggest
but i can't really mandate
that people follow a particular stunt
i actually have a additional comment on
that and um a strategy that i end up
kind of using is
is
yeah obviously it's great for the team
as a whole but it's also great for that
person for their future self
right yeah yeah and everyone everyone
can can uh think of a time where they're
like they look back at work that they've
done they're like what was i thinking
here what did i do and i think when you
kind of pose it that way
you know it ultimately you're right you
just can encourage them but i think when
they are the better version of
themselves three months from now six
months from now that's also a helpful
kind of way to kind of push them
a thousand percent set i mean i i've
said that
you know if i can
the
the polite way of saying it and i'm kind
of rephrasing what i've heard jd long
tweet in the last 48 hours is is be kind
to your future self
right um
when i open up code even a month later i
i often think what the heck was i
thinking of
you know um if i open it up a year later
it's like
i don't even recognize who wrote this
mess
and that's where things like markdown
help because you're leaving that
you know breadcrumb trail that says this
is what i was thinking of where i got
the data from why i'm filtering out this
subgroup of people
um
my my quit that i made at our studio
conf a few years back was you know
if you're writing more
comments than code then write them in
our markdown
if you're writing more code than
comments write more comments and do it
in our markdown
yeah and the decisions of being leading
by example too where if you're building
that community when other people see
your code then they kind of are like wow
it's so much more readable so much more
easy and and you reduce that mental
overhead i think oh yeah oh yeah
i like that mike i see libby and hugh
are commenting uh
similar comments in the chat being
frustrated with themselves looking at
something a month later
i'm one thing
i i'm at an age where i wander into a
room and forget why i came in you know
so
that that's usually only a minute
in the past
he's just say i see you're gonna jump in
yeah i was gonna say what we have is at
the enterprise level we have a
commitment to clean code and so you know
they host workshops or they do lunch and
learns um
and they really try to get you know
people to code better um but it comes
from the higher down so um so you might
be able to find a champion or find
someone to advocate for you on better
code development and worst case scenario
is you just you know have a github
action or something that links their
code or styles it you know
and
at least there you have
something that's a little bit um better
to read yeah and and there's you know
control i is it within
our studio will indent your code even
that's a kind thing
you i see you have your hand raised
yeah can you hear me i can i'm very
curious if you're in an airport and
heading somewhere
and i'm the time zone behind so i've
missed most of the chat
uh
i was gonna ask um you may have already
covered this but for
uh code standardization do you have any
good resources you could recommend
uh for further reading
um
no is this very short answer
um
i would have to pass that back to the
community here
so for writing standardized code
if anyone has tips feel free to put them
in the chat or just come come on live
too
and sharing snippets is a good
start
so our studio has these features where
you can
write snippet of code so you can type a
few words press tab or shift tab it will
auto complete
you can share that snippets um across
team
so
if you want to do a certain task for
certain operations it's going to be the
same code
yeah yeah i was thinking along lines of
like style guides or that kind of thing
that are popular with all our markdowns
um yeah that's that's definitely helpful
sharing snippets is
something we didn't try to do regularly
but
i mean the the tidyvar style guide is a
good place to start as well because
that's commonly used
i see sam also shared the efficient r
programming book that colin wrote
that's the official plug
and i can
i can take some of these
resources here and put them on the
linkedin group too
mike i know we're a little bit over do
you have a few more minutes for the
other questions okay
um sam had asked is visor using the
golem package for shiny app development
or do you have any thoughts on it being
used more broadly in pharma
yeah
um
i don't
think it's used widely
um i think it's an absolutely brilliant
tool
the reason that i'm saying that is that
what i see a lot is colleagues are going
from
nothing to like a prototype app
and so the the scope of use of that app
tends to be within a project or you know
with with a colleague that they'll sit
beside and they're just
you know looking at stuff together
there are few apps
that i know of that have gone from that
prototype to full production
where where gollum and other tools like
that really help is in formalizing that
process from going from you know i've
got my thing that works through to
something that can be tested documented
and it's essentially like a package
um and that's
that i think is the high
kind of
water line no the
high barrier to or or the the the best
solution if you're gonna then
put it into production or even
you know take it to some regulatory
interaction or some external facing
scenario
it's not trivial though
my one attempt to trying to use it for a
semi-complex app
because you you're encouraged to think
in terms of modules
and if you're
not familiar with that then kind of
retrofitting the modules is tough
um
it seems to me though that if you're
wanting to do something quickly
and just for internal use gollum
kind of gives you quite a lot of extra
overhead
so what i'm saying is that if you know
that ultimately this app is going to go
somewhere and go into production it's
fantastic bake it in from day one
um but that it seems overkill for some
other situations where you just want to
pull together something quickly so that
you can demonstrate the
you know the benefits of shiny
that note as well i know um snap finance
built a wrapper for gollum
that they are working on and they wanted
to make that available to the community
as well
so they're gonna speak about that at a
meet-up actually in two weeks so i just
put
the link in the chat if you want to add
it to your calendar
um yeah it's called the grab graveler
package which i realized
now that both are pokemon and i didn't
know that before
um there's two other questions that were
left and one was
when ask for coding help what is your
role do you fix the code and send it
back to them or are you giving them
suggestions and they fix their own code
um
that's a good question
i do not want to be
the person that
the rcoe is i'm really hoping isn't the
place where people punt something over
the fence and say my code so a whole
bunch of rubbish fix it for me
you know because
that means that we'll always just be
there mopping up someone else's mess
um
i would much rather
help people to do better from day one
and that involves them coming to speak
to us from day one
um if i i'm asked to solve a problem and
i develop something
as i said previously i want to get it to
the point where i hand back something
that isn't going to just induce a
massive amount of technical debt
so i want to provide something that i
can say i'll stand behind this
but the code and everything in it should
be tidy enough that you'll know
what to change where to change it and
what will happen when i change it
um
i hope that answers the question because
it's
you know i i'm definitely not wanting to
just give like 3 000 lines of code or 3
000 lines of trying to get you know
that's
thanks mike and um i want to make sure i
haven't missed other people's questions
if you're still on now feel free to just
raise your hand
and let me know
um someone did ask about the roles that
you were hiring for this is anonymously
they said for the technical role that
you mentioned about r what level of
proficiency do you feel can be
considered
well
the technical side of things
actually we're kind of hiring out of
india
um
for the minute just because we've been
told that you know we
are
not wanting to fill those roles kind of
from us-based folks
um but what we're looking for is
people who
effectively you need to i would like to
see put it this way i would like to see
what you have on github
you know so if you can show me good
examples of where you've solved problems
with our
written packages written shiny apps done
clever stuff with our markdown and it's
on github then i would love to see it
um
because
you know it it's easy for someone to say
on paper
oh yes you know i am expert level in r
but it's as we've discussed previously
in these sessions it's hard to know
exactly what that means
you know whereas if you can show me a
github recall well great i can now go
and look at your code and see how tidy
it is how it's structured
how you're building
things thank you arafat i see you have
your hand raised
uh yes
so the last uh i was really curious
about the last comment so when you're
looking for someone's
github link
so
one
like
i feel kind of like you know find me in
the middle of that because
when i have done my works for my
workplace a lot of those projects i
can't really share them publicly or even
discuss in much detail
and also it's kind of difficult to find
the time to do some extensive projects
in my uh that can be shareable
online
so what would be your suggestions in
that case like people who have some like
let's say
some years of experience
and they cannot necessarily find the
time to build something
that can show their expertise and that
can be shareable online
yeah yeah so
again the this has been discussed in a
in a previous data science hangout there
were some excellent discussions
previously about
um i think i think around the lines of
this this question
um
we
are devising a a technical interview
that is scenario based
so i
rather than say you know
get on the meeting use a sketch board
and kind of show me how you would code
this i mean that
that involves you having to know it off
the top of your head and nobody codes
like that in the real world
so the scenario we're looking for is
open-ended
it's you know this is what we're asking
you know this is what's being asked for
how would you go about solving that
problem with r
and then talking kind of in general
terms about you know which packages
might be involved how you would solve
that problem
and certain aspects of that problem as
well like you know
if the data is sitting in pfizer servers
but you want to make it a shiny app how
do you get the data from
here
to
the shiny app
you know because i think
having someone explain to us the ins and
outs of that process
will tell me a little will tell me much
more
about how whether they understand the
technical aspects of building that thing
than live coding or anything else like
that
okay you know it it relies on me having
a wee bit of knowledge about how i might
approach it
but if the
you know if the person in that interview
is covering
all the different bases of security
you know
what happens if someone does something
in an app that is unexpected does it
feel gracefully does it not how do we
handle that how do we ensure that
you know we we can check and test the
app before it gets deployed those kinds
of questions i i think if someone can
answer those well
that's fantastic
if i can augment that by looking on
github and seeing what they have so much
the better
okay great thanks
thank you
thank you all for for the great
questions too i feel like there were so
many questions during the session
thank you mike for for sharing with all
of us i know you shared a bit earlier
your linkedin
and maybe
email but is that the best way to get in
touch with you linkedin
um
yes frankly
awesome and don't forget to buy my album
tomorrow yes
and your band camp there yes
um i did just want to ask you before we
go for people
who maybe are joining
the first one i saw was about pharma are
there other pharma community
sites you'd like to direct us to or work
in groups or where other people can can
get involved
so i know i'll be the plug for oran
pharma
um
so that
that's uh the iron pharma conference
um is in the fall
and it's a great conference it's very
like a
domain specific or studio conference so
people are there to present on
how they solve problems with r
um
rather than focusing on the sciency bits
um but it's it's a really great
conference
i should also plug our studio conference
in the birds of a feather for pharma
right
yes so we do have our studio conference
coming up the end of july so there'll be
birds with feather groups for each
industry or based on your interests
and so pharma is definitely a big one
there
i know there's a few other working
groups through the r consortium
too i can't find the exact links right
now so i'm just going to put the general
link there
it's under
working
groups
in our consortium um there's one on um
submission
uh using r
um
there's one sorry let me
done that nice i just put the working
groups and then the one i just
remembered our validation hub as well
exactly so there's our tables for
regulatory submission
as well
um
and you know so these these are
and fuses the other one actually when i
think about it um it has a stream for
our
um fuse in the past has been
more
kind of sas centric but i think it's
it's gradually migrating over to having
more stuff with our
awesome thanks so much mike
if anybody else on the call has other
links or resources to share feel free
um this is a bit of a ways
out now but i we do also have in our
studio pharma meetup on may 17th
and it's going to be streamed on youtube
live
so i'll just share that link here too
and again all these links shared in the
chat i'll
kind of consolidate and put with the
recording that goes up to youtube as
well
but thank you so much so much mike for
jumping on and and sharing all this
information with us
great to have you thank you
you